German government report says that
Berlin reduced his arms shipments by
almost a quarter last year in 2018 it
cut exports to certain states over their
involvement in the M&E conflict among
them the United Arab Emirates
despite the UAE claiming it acts only to
ensure stability in the region but trade
between Germany and the UAE has just got
a boost prompting fears renewed arm
sales could actually follow if an owner
has more on the story it was clearly a
fruitful meeting but it's left a bitter
taste in the mouth for some the
declaration German Chancellor Angela
Merkel and the Crown Prince of Abu Dhabi
signed in Berlin had 46 points and
focused mainly on business ties between
Germany and the United Arab Emirates but
the conversation apparently went far
beyond that of course we talked about
the conflict in Yemen and I'm very happy
that we agree in our common explanation
there there is a necessity to support
the initiated process of the United
Nations with a UN Special Envoy of
course they talked about Yemen the
United Arab Emirates is the second key
player in the devastating conflict there
after Saudi Arabia and Germany is
reportedly selling its weapons the
reason why the warm welcome of the crown
prince here in Berlin made some
opposition politicians fuming as deputy
commander-in-chief of the UAE Armed
Forces he has access to enormous
financial and military capacities which
he unscrupulously uses to support
autocratic rulers who oppose human
rights in countries such as Egypt Libya
and Sudan which Sheikh Mohammed bin
Saeed Al Nishant received by Merkel and
Steinmeier and then responsible for war
crimes in Yemen now concrete actions not
just strong words are needed the word
crimes of the UAE must not be rewarded
by German arms exports even though there
were no armed deals mentioned this time
the Bundestag opposition found out
earlier that the multi-billion euro
partnership between Germany and the
United Arab Emirates does include some
deadly elements answering to requests by
Germany's left
the federal ministry for Economic
Affairs confirmed yes German weaponry
could go to the UAE and no rules would
be broken the party behind the request
strongly disagrees we talked to its
parliamentary deputy who's also an MP
the federal government violates the arms
exports to the UAE and the other
countries participating in a war in
Yemen which is a violation of the
political principles of the federal
government for the export of war weapons
and other armaments this document
clearly stipulates the delivery of
weapons and arms components is not
approved for countries involved in armed
conflicts or where there is a threat we
contacted the Federal Ministry of
Economic Affairs for clarification but
so far haven't received a response and
while there is still no clear
understanding of whether Germany does
sell or whether it should sell its
weapons to the United Arab Emirates the
public discussion goes on and on last
year Angela Merkel imposed an arms
embargo on Saudi Arabia for its role in
the Yemen war this week she welcomed the
UAE Crown Prince Mohammed bin zaid and
praised strengthened business links with
the Gulf country no mention of arms
exports weapons are delivered to Dubai
the United Arab Emirates in fact there
is no expert band for weapons they are
delivered to the military partners of
Saudi Arabia
people are dying anyway we need an
eu-wide expert ban Germany which at
different times has had various
restrictions over its arm trade with the
United Arab Emirates over Yemen claims
there is no solid evidence that German
made weapons are used in the conflict
and therefore the country's guidelines
have not failed its embargo with Saudi
Arabia still in force and the general
drop in Germany's arm
experts proves that the country that
stands for peace making moves in the
right direction which probably means
that the massive abu dhabi berlin trade
with or without weapons is said to
flourish I think it's the absolute apex
of hypocrisy to be talking business to a
dictator
who is at the same time loitering
civilians bombing hospitals and starving
children to death in Yemen Merkel she is
doing what's convenient and the pressure
from the United States from the arm
suppliers in Germany there's strong
pressure you cannot deny that but the
strong government would stand up to that
pressure and put the interest of the
German population first Mirko doesn't do
that what she is doing is she's thinking
about the 15 nearly 15 billion in trade
between the United Arab Emirates and
Germany she thinking about growing the
German arms industry
you